buonasera buonasera già tutti ciao ciao
ciao
chi non solo un secondo perché devo
attaccare la chitarra e c'è un capo qui
che mi aspettava il fonico stato tutto
perché siamo facciamo un po di casino
bene
vabbè melasuono subito così vi faccio
capire
ci hanno portato qui
per parlare tu lo sai inventarti una
canzone però non ti sei preparato
neanche una slide non era il caso giusto
certo qua con gli speaker che sul palco
tengono botta sei arrivato tu con la
canotta devi almeno metterti qualcosa di
più carino ve lo ricordo io sono un
artista un po cretino mi chiamo elianto
me la suono e me la canto non quello
soltanto inventò le canzoni fatte sulle
persone che qui direi che c'è molto più
di una persona
fatevi un applauso perché siete il telex
di verona
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e ora forse è il caso però di spiegare
magari fermarmi un attimo smettere di
cantare perché questo qui è salito nel
cosa che vuole dire cosa vorrà mai fare
sicuramente si poteva anche preparare
ciao quello che avete appena sentito in
realtà è frutto di due minuti fanno il
bagno mentre faceva pipì
ho pensato più o meno cosa dico adesso
insulti con le slide tutte le robe dell
io no io sono un artista di strada
diciamo uno dei misteri artista di
strada principalmente un improvvisatore
sono un elemento fastidioso nella
quotidianità delle persone
spiego meglio un giorno come tanti
facevo il busker busker il termine figo
per dire artista di strada suonavano le
strade normalmente attacco tutta la
strumentazione a milano c'è bisogno di
un permesso somma diventa una cosa
abbastanza macchinosa quindi quando
trovi delle zone belle in centro sono
rare no quindi tende a starci
avevo tutto non avevo i testi delle
canzoni quindi già cantando wonderwall
come se fossi di alberobello cosa
effettiva non era il caso no di
continuare e quindi mi sono messo a
improvvisare canzoni sui passanti è
stato un idea della serie spirito di
adattamento o mi ammazzano amico di
mazzate
continuo a fare questa cosa e mi è
andata bene
cioè è andata bene devo dire che è stata
un esperimento che ha funzionato quindi
è passata la prima ragazza aspetta con
la bicicletta e per fortuna si è fermata
perché se non si fossero messe armata in
questa roba non poteva inventare vabbè
io sono l'anello di congiunzione tra il
creativo e il cretino è un l'ho scritto
anche sui biglietti da visita
così e per fare questo gioco ovviamente
non posso adesso dal palco per mezz'ora
cantare su una folla perché siete tanti
e io normalmente o il pubblico a livello
dei miei piedi quindi ora farò un
esperimento chiederò una partecipazione
questo è un oggetto di altissima
tecnologia che ora lancerò a caso così
come notate chi non sono uno sportivo
cioè suonavo la chitarra
sono arrivato dalla seconda fila ci
commesso linea energia pazzesco va bene
e chiedo gentilmente di raggiungermi ti
ho colpito in faccia
no no no non ti ho fatto male da non
prego prego diventerà il mio spartito
umano come si suol dire posso posso
sapere il tuo nome anzi se possiamo dare
un gelato così avrà capacità di
rispondere come ti chiami in argentina
cantina e grazie innanzitutto una pausa
cristina che poteva benissimo dire
poteva benissimo dire no io non gioco
sto qua torna a casa o continua a fare
le cover come i falò e invece ce l'ha
fatta cristina cosa cosa fai livello
nella vita consulente di organizzazione
aziendale fa rima con niente consulente
di organizzazione aziendale
senti quante z ci sono in questa frase
dove vieni vieni più vicino cristiana
non volevo non vogliono tenerti lontano
dal cerchio rosso il tuo colore
preferito rosso che è evidente no cioè
un sacco di cose rosso quindi rosso
cristina di dove sei
brescia ok quindi in trasferta torna
stasera ti sei fatta un giro verona nel
frattempo ha avuto tempo da ieri dopo
magari due big
no non lo so tipo il tuo sogno nel
cassetto
il mio sogno nel cassetto e potere
lavorare in giro per il mondo come
qualcuno ha detto che probabilmente si
potrebbe già fare ma ok ok quindi avere
un posto fisso ma non essere fissi di
base cioè nomadi è l'artista di strada
corà grafica si trovi un talento non c'è
bisogno di suonare e vediamo hai uno
sport preferito yoga è uno sport
se ti sentono i maestri di yoga quelli
veri cristina cioè c'è un cecchino là in
alto con una volontà pechino ha scritto
infatti mi piace meditare come ok però
dai ok yoga facciamo che io abbia uno
sport e ai un piatto preferito cioè ami
cucinare no no a rimangiare però si
tende a farlo per sopravvivere quindi
una maglia aggiunge e che che piano
anche pianto ti piace a tante cose il
riso a me piace il risorto il senso in
tutte le sue sfumature
va bene sei tempo di rimanere con
secondo come facciamo la canzone
improvvisata una pausa ancora cristina
che si presta a questa cosa è una
tonalità che preferisci ma guarda ovvio
ma se sei un tipo un po da solo quindi
suoniamo in sol si facciamo che non è un
sold mafai
diciamo che interessa cristina
ora mi aiuterai con questa prossima rima
e per fortuna sia stata carina e non una
stronzata è salita sul palco
immediatamente per improvvisare insieme
a me davanti a tutta questa gente
dicendomi che tu di mestiere fai la
consulente di organizzazione aziendale
senti che mestiere romantico da cantare
va bene fa niente ma si può fare lo
stesso sì perché poi sul tuo colore
preferito non era evidente fosse rosso
ma se comunque una bella persona e poi
guarda che di rosso ti va di spiga se
vai a pamplona per dire lascia stare
ancora una volta ci possiamo provare
questa è la mia unica sfiga quella di
cantare continuamente e con un po di
foga domandarmi adesso che cosa dico su
uno sport che non è uno sport perché
yoga cioè non aveva niente ne parliamo
comunque
[Applauso]
[Musica]
io nel frattempo mi arrampico con le
unghie sopra gli specchi come un gatto
con anche il sapone per ricordarmi cosa
mi hai detto tra i sogni nel cassetto
quello di viaggiare come fanno certo
tante altre persone quindi un po zingara
gipsy col computer ci può stare
quali altri dettagli e mai dovuto dare
che sei venuta qua in trasferta perché
sei di brescia non è mangiato niente
prima in pausa pranzo si meno male sennò
digiuno va bene che fa io voghera però
esce da no non mi sembrava carino
vi ringrazio cristina recenti da quel
che leggo sul tuo cartellino frase
questo questo esperimento di
improvvisazione lo si può replicare
anche in maniera più ampia diciamo
vendita di mi stanno rilanciando il mio
volano e sarebbe bello provare a fare
una dinamica come quelle di strada
perché come potete immaginare io non è
che devo fare tutta l'intervista ogni
persona in strada
li vedo passare in maniera maleducata
dico quello che penso in rima cantando
da paraculo cioè funzionano se non lo si
arrabbia quindi ora provo un altro
lancio da campione di quelli di prima e
proviamo a far salire una fila intera
giusto
nessuno mi dava segni di come si può
fare lo facciamo
sei pronto in questo è un lancio
pazzesco dai questo dato vecchio ma
sempre secondo terza fila beppe guarda
che quindi 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 persone
gentilmente mi fatto questo regalo
salite da quella parte
e fate un giro un giro di palco
tranquilli
speravate di stare seduti a non far
nulla adesso è l'ultimo poi devo
mangiare un applauso un applauso
siamo pronti non vi chiederò il nome
sarà un po maleducato premi di immobili
da allora no prego le più difficile 10 7
dai facciamo
[Musica]
canzone improvvisata fatta adesso per
loro 10 che speravano di non essere
chiamati invece un ave toccata prego
venite qua davanti a sfilare che nel
frattempo provero a cantare tutto quello
che mi pare sono impauritissimi
resteranno lì tutta la sera
lascio stare questo gioco si può fare
nessuno si nasconde di trombe lo da un
sinonimo comprare i ragazzi li faccio
pure atteso lampadario le rime certo non
dietro il sipario arriva a lui con la
camicia bianca e la scarpa di vernice ti
sa dice tu invece con le paillettes
l'altra con la maglietta a righe conosce
le sfighe questi quanto cazzo stava
andando veloci m'aspettavo fossero più
lenti fermati qua ragazza col cardigan e
capello corto meno male non vero neanche
accorto che eravate partiti da fermi a
correre sul parco immediatamente lo so
che non è carino tirare in mezzo così la
gente ma si può fare comunque i marmi
con le unghie ingrandendo sulle persone
brecko sfilate entrate ci può stare la
sciarpa della seduta a togliere perché
faceva un caldo qui sopra si può a
schiantare e poi ci sei tu con questo
maglione ti avranno regalato ti hanno
costretto a metterlo che la verità non
l'hai comprato anche la camicia e si
poteva mare certo io lo sei tu
passa il ragazzo con la giacca blu color
facebook quindi deduco abbia a che fare
col mondo dissocia
no ma le dicono in romagna c'è chi mi
insegna e c'è chi va di corsa
hai fatto bene a portarla sulla borsa
perché qua sacco di gente che prega le
cose io resto delle prose a fare questo
gioco
scherzando con il fuoco
tranquilli adesso la canzone si può fare
l'abbiamo finita io possono lasciarmi
andare
grazie davvero grazie l'applauso stati
carinissimi carinissimi missili davvero
davvero
[Applauso]
e in realtà c'era c'era un sottotitolo
con la foto da hipster con la pipa no
mentre facevo il figo improvvisare dal
palco alla vita e ci tenevo a
raccontarvi questa esperienza perché ho
lavorato in vari contesti creativi e
quello più rilevante realtà è stato
oltre ovviamente il mondo dello
spettacolo e le robe belle divertenti
cioè c'entra sia stato anche lavorare
per la pubblicità e io ho fatto il mio
primo colloquio in strada cioè led
creative che poi mi ha chiesto
effettivamente di venire a lavorare per
lui stava camminando con la moglie per
strada e io ho cominciato a dire che la
moglie era bellissima la figlia anche e
lui era un cesso atomico quindi non si
spiegava questa cosa cioè doveva essere
molto ricco infatti lo era tra l'altro
quindi torna si è preso molto bene e in
qualche modo sono finito a inveire
essere cattivo ma detto queste parole tu
le sai anche scrivere tu mi sai pagare
se lo faccio parte e quindi c'è stato
effettivamente un colloquio lì mi sono
improvvisato a tutti gli effetti
copywriter ma come un improvviso nella
vita un sacco di cose quello che ci
tengo a dire ea dirvi lasciandovi questo
messaggio no non ancora un sacco di
tempo campo un'altra canzone no non è
vero non ci tenevo a dirvi soprattutto
che nella vita meno nelle cose che fate
di tutti i giorni tipo tutti quei
ragazzi la e sono i volontari che hanno
partecipato che sono entrati in man
bassa
loro a tutti gli effetti si stanno
improvvisando giusto cioè quello che
state facendo
bisogna improvvisando un lavoro ma è
normale cioè nella vita a chiunque lo fa
chiedeva un colloquio e dice davvero
cosa pensa cioè non è non può esistere
deve improvvisare quello che loro
vogliono che tu sia e quindi in ti
cimenti quindi questa capacità di fare
questa roba qui buffa sulle persone
am è servita molto anche nel resto e
credo che sia solamente grazie alla
capacità di adattamento che tutti gli
esseri umani hanno certificato non vince
più forte vince quello che si sa
adattare quindi davanti alla difficoltà
tipo il colloquio difficile fidatevi che
improvvisando forse è il modo giusto per
sfangarla vi lascio con un'ultima
canzone nel frattempo da esattamente tre
minuti da ora
[Musica]
un po d'ispirazione cielo anche per the
cameraman che sei qui sotto il palco e
quella camera non ti vede ma fa niente
quelli a casa che vedranno il filmato
registrato si domanderanno questo di
cosa sta cantando non lo so ma ne
trattengono cambiar canale col
telecomando perché non puoi lo so certo
questo gioco e lo stesso e ti chiudi un
occhio perché ci vedi meglio da dentro
l'obiettivo di ricordo le rime non le
scrivo le posso dire così un pochino a
caso per l'ispirazione dall'area nel
naso aspetta cameraman vieni qui come ti
chiami come ti chiami what's your name
come ti chiami i voti voti ricordo le
rime non le scrivo elemento tutte quante
così le prendo al volo aspetta ma tu sei
vivo di fabio volo un proprio quello più
puro e la canzone senza un ritornello si
può inventare
salutami quell'altro nel frattempo che
vive solo al mare ma lui lo può fare
mentre io non sono qui a cantare una
canzone improvvisata cucinata sul
momento e lo faccio così prendendo un po
tutto il volo la barba ce l'ho mi manca
la panza potrei diventare il
cannavacciuolo e invece no vicino a
questa cosa così perché questo è il mio
gioco è una specie di masterchef dove il
piatto è come una stella cadente e
l'improvvisazione l'avete inventato a
voi perché se della giusta ispirazione
sede alla gente siete la cosa giusta
equa non c'è truccano cercando nessuno
adesso tirerà fuori il nome da una busta
ve lo posso assicurare
la canzone 1843 evitiamo dovrà pure
terminare mi servirebbe non so una frase
o una parola che qualcuno ne urli una
che non sia per favore lo sbarco sulla
luna
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma adesso lasciatemi dire giusto così
per chiusura che siete stati un pubblico
fantastico questo gioco è il mio è una
specie di bungee jumping senza elastico
io posso cadere mi posso pure spalmare
ancora una volta certo che c'è chi si
addice c'è chi non capisce e qualcuno
addirittura che traduce perché vede
sempre le cuffie mi sto domandando il
traduttore cosa sta dicendo tutta questa
marea di parole fa niente le faccio alla
luce del sole
un'altra volta sicuramente non si è
sciolta sotto questi fari ancora una
volta tra sinonimo un contrario ve lo
ricordo io mi chiamo elianto le rime le
faccio appeso al lampadario e stasera lo
fate per voi anche se non c'è il sipario
[Musica]
grazie
grazie grazie davvero
non mi hanno restituito il volano sono
potevamo andare avanti tutta la sera